let's talk about uh let's get let's get
in deep on the uh dni dna ratcliffe
talking about the durham intelligence
reports and what's going on we have the
story from fox news former dni ratcliffe
told durham intelligence supports
multiple indictments in probe hillary
clinton purportedly approved a plan to
distract the public from her email
scandal sources told fox news
yo
trump was right
everything the trump supporters were
saying about why this is happening uh
not all of it but a lot of it turns out
to be true hillary clinton was embroiled
in this scandal where she destroyed
public records
they say emails no no let's slow down
here a minute
on the on the merits on the on the
substance hillary clinton had public
records she destroyed them her staffers
were smashing phones with hammers
this is not about her emails
it's about something very very serious
and then the report comes out she
decided to distract from this news by
accusing trump of being a russian spy
which took over the media in this
country for years here's the story from
fox news former director of national
intelligence john ratcliffe met with
special counsel john durham on more than
one occasion and told him there was
evidence in the intelligence to support
the indictments of multiple people in
his investigation into the origins of
the trump russia probe
fox news first reported on durham's
latest filing which alleged that lawyers
from hillary clinton's presidential
campaign in 2016 had paid to infiltrate
servers belonging to trump tower and
later the white house
in order to establish an inference and
inference and narrative to bring the
federal government agencies linking
donald trump to russia
let me just stress that point hillary
clinton's campaign
paid for the infiltration the breach of
servers belonging to president of the
united states
to accuse him of being a russian asset
or spy or linked yo
okay i don't see that as treason by the
official definition but how is that not
cons seditious conspiracy
it is
completely yeah and it's mind-boggling
because um
watergate was bad right we were talking
about this before and and and um uh
bernstein is uh he's famous for saying
over and over again it's worse than
watergate worse than watergate and i did
watergate and it's worse than watergate
this really is worse than watergate
because watergate was bad right it was a
lot of bad actors um private individuals
but to use the apparatus of government
which has so many checkpoints that's
supposed to stop this from happening i
mean you just can't and i've worked in
the federal government when i was in the
bush administration you just can't get
access to these servers to these tools
to these listening devices to these
spying devices whatever it is you have
to go through so many checkpoints and to
go through those checkpoints people have
to approve it and there's got to be a
process so so it's not one or two or
three or four or a dozen people
implicated it's literally hundreds of
people who are like wait a second ian
why do you need this special like
satellite why why are you doing this why
are you trying to hack into this server
in trump tower and you have to get your
bosses a sign off here and lydia needs
to co-sign and triplicate and
lots of people are involved in this and
they all knew what they were doing was
wrong and and so to use the power of
government again for the crime
of
just not being aligned to the to the the
powers that be right donald trump is you
were allowed to do this if they thought
he was a a a cartel operative right
you're allowed to spy on people's phones
police do it to to citizens all the time
if there's implication that they're
doing something illegal but
trump's crime is
i wanted to win
there's that lawyer who was involved in
trump's first impeachment the ukraine
gate scandal who tweeted right when
trump got inaugurated we are going to
impeach him yeah
and then did
and it's just brazen
and out in the open and obvious
but that's why i've been saying i don't
see any out from this other than some
kind of civil war
because
they're saying it publicly what they're
doing they published a time magazine
article called the shadow campaign to
save the election or whatever explaining
everything they did
and it's in your face
so my question is
when the democrats and the uniparty
establishment types
set up the january 6th committee and
they're filing all these subpoenas
against former trump administration
officials members of the media
at minimum to answer one of these
subpoenas to a hundred thousand dollars
they say
because you can't just be like sure what
do you want no that you have to search
all the labor hours all the legal
responses and legal filings i don't know
how the average person would even be
able to deal with something like that
then you have the durham investigation
now uh former dna ratcliffe saying
multiple
indictments are possible based on this
evidence and there's already been i
think how many how many indictments have
they been in in durham is there two or
one
susman sussman and the other guy right
yeah i think just two yeah but these are
these are building up and potentially
leading to more
do you think either side in this
conflict is going to be like let's just
stop no so what happens when neither
side stops
it escalates
or they can start making concessions
because if if you really didn't want to
stop and you want to go into these
public records that got destroyed and
the copies of them you see sydney
blumenthal's interactions with hillary
and like running guns into libya with
osprey global solutions setting up the
america like a puppet state in libya you
know basically betraying our president
obama who didn't want hillary working
with sydney at all
like if they want to go if they really
want to go all the way
uh but i don't think that it could ever
happen i think that it's they're going
to play a limited war when it comes to
this kind of thing take pieces accept
defeat and they're not going to they're
not going to really blow it open because
if they really blow it open then the
liberal economic order is over but why
would they why would they stop like so
so
well i think it would it would get
stopped i don't by what by who by the
american
secret military
what i don't know i think if you really
start to pry into the secret records
that hillary was trying to destroy you
realize she was trying to destroy him
for a reason because they're they're
covering up the american war machine in
a lot of the way that it subterfuges its
way into countries but ian that is
hillary clinton and everything they did
against donald trump for years accusing
him of being a russian spy it's now
being uncovered that they're they're
they've been faking this whole thing to
try and stop trump and it didn't work
they did it to bernie too the dnc spied
on bernie um i don't have to report spot
on him i don't i i want to be careful
because i know that there was a lot of
foul play with the bernie sanders for
sure okay
i don't have it pulled up i don't know
it's been like what seven years since
the stuff was going on so it's been a
while but bernie absolutely i think bent
the knee to the the democratic
establishment and just gave them yeah
there's emails about bernie talking
about should we use his jewish uh
ancestry against him in the in the
campaign wikileaks emails right yeah
wikileaks i think is just hillary's dump
was wikileaks dumped it it was the dccc
right the democrat the d triple c but
and again and as bad as that is
politics is a is a scummy business and
if that's private actors being scummy
people i understand it was his own
political party doing it yes awful awful
terrible thing but this is using the
government to do it and that's a lot
different because the government is
funded by the taxpayers and it's
supposed to be the under the authority
of congress that represents the will of
the people and that's why this is a
whole new level of scary because it's
not the d triple c it's not political
campaigns and you've worked on political
campaigns they're vicious and nasty heck
we were just talking about a potential
candidate who maybe was attempted
assassination because political
campaigns are nasty but to use the power
of the federal government which is
supposed to be above all of that is a
whole level that we have yet to ever see
in this country and that's that's the
undoing of the nation seditious
conspiracy yes it was a year years-long
effort of what we're all learning about
the with the durham investigation with
the tampering of evidence was it what
that one lawyer who got indicted he like
uh he withheld evidence or something
susman yeah and well his first pfizer um
request to the fisa court which was
rejected and then he got a second one
and he did get his fisa so he's gonna
say look i i was listening to the trump
white house legally i got my fisa
documents but he forged all of the
evidence to go to go to the fisa court
then there was um it was uh
who was it papadopoulos
who was a a cia asset on that email and
they removed it to you know what i'm
talking about yeah i don't remember the
specific details suffice it to say they
were lying about almost everything to
use the power of the courts to hurt
trump's presidency and to stop him from
being able to lead the way the american
people wanted him to and this is based
on this story so this is this is just
broke this this story just broke but i'm
talking about a whole bunch of other
stories their investigation is more than
just this one moment
it was i mean heck it's three years in
the making now at this point the durham
investigation right it's been going on
for a while and it's just starting to
come to light a lot i mean the mueller
probe
you know uh investigating donald trump
to the tune of millions of dollars
inhibiting his ability to do his job as
president because they said oh but if he
fires comey it will be obstruction of
justice comey was basically protected
fbi you know fbi protecting his job by
investigating the president on
completely bunk bs wow it is the bureau
we won't say deep state we'll say the
bureaucratic state the people who are
appointed these positions who stay in
these positions longer than the people
elected to run the offices and they
don't want to lose their jobs and they
found a way to stop trump from purging
them and then when you and then your
head starts to explode when you go to
the jeffrey epstein just lane maxwell
case and you say who was the the the
government lawyer who said that she
could keep all of her clients
confidential oh it's comey's daughter
yeah i have to that's where you become
just crazy and you're like i'm gonna i'm
gonna go bonkers like do they all are
they all related everyone's dating each
other married to each other they all
know each other it's like in hollywood
when you're out partying one night and
then all of a sudden they're like hey
come on you go to a party and like all
the celebrities are there and you're
like what the heck it's like it's in
that house right there but you don't
know what another reality right over
there across the street
another like alternative universe that
you're not part of that you experience
just for one second and then it all
disappears on you it's real yeah those
people probably are a lot of those
people probably are deeply in in contact
of course birds of a feather flock
together so they all hang out they'll
party together and they view it as
normal
so when donald trump comes in and he's
not a part of that club they just say
like let's shut them down and no one's
going to cross anybody that they know
they don't care this is why i say you
know
i was talking earlier about the joe
rogan stuff and we'll get into that in a
second
and i'm just like i i really don't care
what these people think about him and i
think it was a mistake for him to
apologize because all it does is prove
that their tactic worked and it got a
rise out of him like they trolled him
effectively and i'm just like at this
point
you're not going to convince any of
these people because they hate you and
they don't want to like you and they
don't want to be friends with you they
want to high-five their buddy while
making fun of you
there's no point at which the nerdy kid
walks with the bully and says look i'm
sorry we got beef i don't want to you
know get in your face let's be friends
and the boy just push you down and say
wow that was funny and that's and that's
where we're at because
there's there's there's there's an
in-group and an out group
there are separate groups whatever it is
and the democratic establishment and the
media establishment they all view
themselves as the establishment in the
end group but there's a growing faction
of anti-anti-establishment
uh individuals who don't align with them
that's what they fear and i think
they're losing i think the decentralized
internet movement the more youthful free
and libertarian mindset is actually
winning and expanding and we're watching
it with the cultural decay of like the
super bowl the joe rogan smears we're
watching it with what they thought they
could pull off because i'll put it this
way
if the establishment political party was
as powerful as they had been 20 30 years
ago donald trump would not have become
president no there would never be an
investigation it would never be
uncovered that hillary clinton did this
it would just be evil donald trump
colluded and he's in prison but because
they've lost so much of their their
power as they wane and crumble they're
being exposed but they still it's like
it's kind of sad you know it's like
looking off to the old you know the the
old castle crumbling and there's like a
withered old king you know scraggly i'm
still in charge and no one cares and no
one listens anymore yeah that that could
be the only thing that could potentially
save us from from the the the coming
civil war or as you said like we're
probably in some sort of a cold civil
war but one that actually does turn
violent and and what could possibly save
us as the dismantling of the larger
government state that maybe you elect
the right person who's not left not
right maybe just anti-establishment who
does take what used to be good about
both parties you had rand paul and you
had ron wyden both say the patriot act
is bad right like this is bad we should
not be listening to people's emails we
should not this is this is bad for the
country right whatever that part that
used to unite some of the left and the
right
maybe that person could find their way
into into the seat of power and
dismantle a lot of these institutions
and these agencies that just have i mean
there are thousands of people right now
listening to us and their little
government nsa is not very far from here
right i mean a couple of 70 miles and
and they're there and they're listening
and this is their job and the question
is are you keeping our country safe i
don't i don't know if in their mind you
are in their mind they are and it's it
goes back to the great will smith movie
which was 20 years ahead of its time
enemy of the state i mean if you haven't
seen it it's just oh man it's been a
long time since i saw that and it's so
far ahead of its time it's so so i
wonder if will smith i i probably
wouldn't want to enter into politics if
you ever asked him but it is highly
libertarian in its principles
and it's and it's yeah and that's that's
kind of where we are that's what needs
to save the country is the dismantling
of this of this apparatus
term limits for administrative state for
for staff yeah yeah that's maybe maybe
uh
you can only work in federal government
for a certain amount of years before you
you force retire
you can i agree with that like yeah yeah
trying to trying to trying to remove the
people is different than trying to
change the system because if you remove
the people more will come you know we
got to fix the system i'm like literally
getting flashbacks right now like the
democratic establishment so reminds me
of like an abusive ex-boyfriend or
something because listen listen listen
they project i don't know if you guys
have ever been in like a situation where
the other person you're dating is always
accusing you of cheating always accusing
you of being disloyal disloyal but
they're the ones that's cheating the
whole time and i could see the parallel
from the russia gate they're talking
about trump colluding with russia russia
russia now it's flipped back out flip
back on them it just it just so reminds
me of being in an abusive relationship i
guess for all we know it was the kgb
with working with hillary to push the
russia
uh and there's no kgb anymore what are
you talking about of course there's no
kgb anymore they all disappeared
i don't really believe that they were
working with hillary clinton but that'd
be funny if you saw the full circle
yeah honestly at this point if the
democrats accuse someone of doing
something else you need to check and
make sure that they're not doing that
because the odds are good that that is
exactly what they're doing and this is
sololinsky's rules for radicals right
like this is something that they do not
play around with they take it very
seriously and it looks like that's what
the exactly what they're doing here it
is the fsb which stands for the federal
security service oh that sounds nice um
maybe it's a different word that's
russian so yeah right yeah maybe it's
federal security bureau they call it or
whatever but fsb is the but uh you know
in reality i mean i think putin was kgb
yeah they these people don't didn't just
cease to exist they just reformed under
different names
yeah and now they're all focused on the
ukraine
oh yeah what's up with yeah i don't
think that's that wasn't one of the
stories we picked up tonight but is this
all propaganda what's going on
yeah i think i think it's uh the us is
we've talked about it a bit every so
often
when uh obama was in you had this
growing escalation and conflict in
ukraine
donald trump gets elected
conflict stops where'd it go where'd it
go
so when they try and come out and say oh
this is vladimir putin doing all of this
i think it's possible that putin is
being uh
effectively you know rope-a-doped or
roped into it
because
the u.s wants
wants ukraine and nato they want to
build their pipeline they want to
control natural gas into europe russia
controls a large portion of natural gas
going into europe which causes high
prices the u.s have been trying to
offset this they need ukraine on their
side because the pipes gas problem runs
through ukraine and so under obama
you have this uh this protest movement
which is
in support of westernization of ukraine
russia doesn't want that because russia
has their military base in crimea so
they invade crimea and that whole thing
happens
when trump gets in
the conflict stopped
when trump is out and biden's in the
conflict reignites so you tell me who's
who's starting the fight damn i i i
think it's the democratic establishment
trump had no interest in going to war
russia they took crimea but then after
uh donald trump gets in it starts to die
down my friends in ukraine are like oh
we don't really call it a civil war it's
just separatists that are fighting but
they've been losing now that biden's
back and all of a sudden all the troops
are here and it's getting worse and it's
getting crazier propaganda i think the
u.s the i i shouldn't say the u.s i feel
bad for what's become of our country
under the under the thumb of these
crackpot despots like the the democratic
establishment the republican
establishment the neocons and neolibs
these are deeply deeply evil people they
think
they have a right to to to destroy to
invade because the ends justify the
means and they'll tell you to your face
and look you in the eyes and say all of
the great luxuries you've experienced in
your life are because we sacrificed for
you because we went to war and we stole
and we plundered and we enslaved and my
response to these people is like what
makes you think i'm okay with any of
that and they're like well you got all
these computers you got all this great
technology all from the petrol dollar
i'm like bro i have no problem living
with some chickens and building myself a
little cabin and living a simpler life
but they don't want that the powerful
establishment they want to be the
dictators they want to control they want
the empire and they think the american
people live a slightly higher standard
of living every time we do this we're
going to keep doing it
those aren't my morals i don't agree
with that they seem to and so they do
what they do under donald trump his
principles were no if the american
people work hard and work for each other
we'll be successful and we'll have
things for ourselves and the amer
america first protect our borders and
i'm like that makes sense to me the
neocon neil neolibe establishment is
like no if we just put pressure on other
countries and put them under our boot we
don't need to do any work at all we'll
just get free money
yeah i also think since the time of
of of
since the dawn of man but i mean just
looking at the at the ancient romans
since caesar
i think every
leader this may be a guy statement no
offense to the ladies in the room but i
think every male leader has felt like i
will truly be a leader when i take my
people to war i feel like the wartime
president is like an aspiration sadly
and i think it's a terrible thing um and
i i wouldn't be surprised if obama had a
little bit of that bush certainly had
that bush cheney um and i think i think
biden has that a little bit as well like
when i go to war and i lead my army
then i am the manhood of of of the
president the fullness of men now that i
noticed a name you didn't say
i don't think trump had that he did not
i don't think he cared
he got painted as the overly like macho
thinking that he had something to prove
blah blah blah
he did not start a new war i love it
when he came out on that that one famous
moment where he was asked about a
weapons deal with saudi arabia and he's
just like it's great we're going to make
a lot of money it's going to be really
good for the economy it's billions and
billions of dollars and these anti-war
leftists were just like he just admitted
what the us does trump didn't care about
going to war he didn't want our troops
he even said why do we still have troops
in germany yes why do we have troops in
these other countries why do we
i mean quite frankly we have hundreds of
thousands of troops all over the world
30 000 in germany 20 000 in italy 40 000
in in in south korea japan i mean yeah
in okinawa and we why why why why is it
why are we still defending japan like
their their economy is is
not as good as ours but it's pretty darn
good their their quality of life and
sophistication and technology is as good
as ours why are we why why what are we
doing i'll tell you something
interesting i saw a meme
it was a post on 4chan of the when when
it was uh what was it philadelphia
firebombed that uh that that
neighborhood you guys remember that can
you look that up
yeah yeah yeah uh see i don't even know
the full details on it but they said ask
the average chinese person about
tiananmen square and they won't they
won't be able to tell you what it is
show them this picture and ask them what
it is and show an american this picture
ask them what it is and they won't be
able to tell you either this is uh the
1985 move bombing refers to the may 13
1985 incident in philadelphia
pennsylvania united states when the
philadelphia police force department
police department bombed the residential
home occupied by the militant move
organization what it's not the same
thing as cinnamon square but i only mean
you know
a peaceful protest of college students
and like the philadelphia fire
department let the subsequent fire burn
out of control following a standoff so
they basically burn these people alive
right crap and there's waco and there's
that we we have our bad moments oh sure
but the reason i bring this up is uh not
to derail but most most americans
probably couldn't tell you they probably
don't know how many military bases
around the world we have they don't know
they're living at the heart of the
empire
yeah 113 at least or 100 some i don't
know the actual but it's a lot of the
submarines we don't know about nobody
knows about and that's why it's funny if
you ever listened or follow on social
media um
now the olympics and people are like how
come everyone seems to speak english
that's why you know yes our cartoons and
our movies and hollywood and all that
but why do all these people speak
english it's not because of of
they like our tv shows it's because the
american military might why did everyone
speak latin or back then actually
ancient greek because they ruled the
world and no matter where you went the
empire you spoke the common language
because they were in charge why does
everyone speak english and who's trying
to supplant that it's not germany and
it's not south africa and it's not
chile
it's china and they want everyone to
start speaking mandarin but that is
their goal but trump was just like why
are we doing any of this yeah build
factories in america
and the establishment was like shut him
up see what people need to understand is
americans produce relatively little to
the amount of our uh to the amount of
wealth we have because we control the
petro dollar you want to buy oil you
want to use oil it's our dollar that you
you got to use to do it and well the
united states makes dollars so that
means loans go out to americans on
demand we then have those dollars we can
buy more things but for other countries
they have to buy dollars first
other countries have to produce large
quantities to be able to have a high
enough gdp to trade for dollars to to
get more access we in america we we live
luxury off of relatively little compared
to many other countries and someone is
trying to supplant that and the neocons
will tell you we need to have all of
these bases especially in and and you
mentioned japan and and the uh
and the pacific because we have to keep
the shipping routes open and trump would
say why don't we just move the factories
back to america and we don't have to
keep the trade routes open why do we
need to have the navy make sure we can
get our vessels from china without them
being taken over by pirates how about we
just make everything here and then i
don't care what happens on the high seas
wrong thing
wrong think exactly exactly paradigm
shifts are hard for people and that's
where the the left and the right
the paradigm shift of whatever trump was
we're like
no that's not how we do things i love i
love this comment someone sent me when i
tweeted about the celebrities of the
super bowl not wearing masks they said
things are looking pretty good in the
capitol but it's a little rough out here
in the districts yeah and i'm just like
interesting yup that would be uh hunger
games yes that's right
the in the hunger games film i love it
when when uh they go to the party and
the rich people are oblivious to how
awful life is for the average person and
they're drinking ipac to vomit and keep
eating yeah and i thought about this and
i said those celebrities the super bowl
are the victors in the hunger games in
the hunger games the poor people from
the districts once they win they get to
go to the capitol and be rich and go on
tour and laugh and gloat that's what
these celebrities are they're not
members of the political establishment
elite they're not part of that powerful
industry club
they're the people who are lifted up and
put out there as the face to keep
everyone in deep slumber and you know
live so long as they say the right
things
but as joe rogan is experiencing if you
have said anything that bucks the system
then they need to take you down we were
driving home from the cabin yesterday
went to this cabin up in pennsylvania
and i was saying
life is so good i was talking thinking
or saying it and then i thought for me
right now and then i just thought about
all these people that it's not like i
was just like life in general is amazing
for me because i was born in the united
states with some money these poor people
man and then i started to get depressed
and that was like shaking me out of my
my mode where i need to be to help
people
bro the last thing you'll ever want to
do is read about henry kissinger
read about him and africa and all that
stuff and you will probably cry yourself
to sleep you hear about what this what
what the the i don't want to see the
united states it's it's the global power
structure but you know about the
international monetary fund the swift
system how they control people the
things they do man
you know they think they're smarter they
think they're better than you and
they're deeply deeply amoral people who
view humans as cattle
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you